former US president Donald Trump has
been splitting his time between
courtrooms and the campaign Trail late
this afternoon a jury in New York
reached a verdict in his defamation
trial at issue whether Trump damaged
magazine columnist eege Carroll's
reputation by denying he raped her and
how much in Damages he should pay let's
bring in our Jackson prco now Jackson
the jury said the former president must
pay much more than the $24 million
Carol's lawyers had been calling for a
whole more you through the Manhattan
jury ordered Trump to pay $83 million to
egene Carroll for defaming her ever
since she made her original rape
accusation back in 2019 the settlement
includes $1 million to fund a
reputational repair campaign and another
7.3 million for emotional harm that she
suffered during the course of the trial
Carol testified that she was frightened
by persistent attacks from Trump and his
supporters and that her reputation was
shattered now this is the second award
she has received after a different jury
found Trump liable for sexually abusing
her back in the mid 90s in a department
store dressing room Trump says he's
going to appeal he calls this a Biden
directed Witch Hunt which is not at all
true remember this was a civil suit
brought by a private individual and the
damages were awarded by a jury of
ordinary citizens but given the
ferociousness of Trump's attacks the
judge offered this advice to jurors
never disclose that you were on this
jury ethu
and as this has been going on Trump has
also been fueling tensions over illegal
migration along the US Mexico border
Jackson we know that in December alone
roughly
250,000 migrants crossed the southern
border into the us but where do things
stand today well with Trump's
encouragement Republican governors in
half of the country are now backing
Texas in this legal standoff with the
federal government and it's intensifying
concerns about a potential
constitutional crisis in the
making the razor wire on the southern
border is a sharp message of defiance
from Texas where the governor ordered
the state's national guard to block
migrants from crossing the Rio Grand
claiming Texas faces an invasion what
Texas is asserting is our article one
section 10 right of self-defense the
Supreme Court disagrees this week it
ordered Texas to allow Federal border
patrol agents to remove the wire what we
want is border patrol to be able to do
their jobs and right now Governor Abbott
is getting in the way Texas won't back
down and is refusing to acknowledge the
Court ruling or federal authority over
the border the appearance of Asylum
Seekers and even large amounts of Asylum
Seekers at the border is not the type of
invasion that the constitution talks
about make no mistake this is entirely
about election year politics Republicans
under Donald Trump want to make
migration the central issue in the
presidential campaign 25 Republican Le
states are now backing Texas some have
sent their own National Guard troops to
the Border in doing so they've brought
the US to the brink of a constitutional
crisis this is the exact thing that the
United States went through in its first
70 to 80 years of existence leading to
eventually the secession of states and
the Civil War back in Washington a
bipartisan group of lawmakers is working
on a border Bill to deal with the record
surge in migrants but hopes of passing
the legislation have fallen apart As
Trump signals he wants to campaign on
Border chaos the idea that someone
running for president would say please
hurt the country so I can blame my
opponent and help my politics is a uh a
shocking uh uh
development and you know the delay on
passing a border Bill isn't just adding
to the tension in Texas aid for Ukraine
and Israel are tied up here too so
Republicans who worked on that bill are
now worried that if they're trying to
keep Trump happy but fail to pass the
bill they'll actually end up wearing
blame for the crisis at the border by
the time the election rolls around in
November meu Jackson prco in Washington
thanks Jackson